possible fentanyl exposure inside a
state prison the 8 news now
investigators have been exposing issues
within the Nevada Department of
Corrections for some time Vanessa Murphy
has this latest concern
sources tell us a correctional officer
was exposed to a substance believed to
be possible fentanyl while searching a
cell that officer was seen at a hospital
and is expected to be okay now this
happened at High Desert State Prison
about a 40-minute drive outside of Las
Vegas the Nevada Department of
Corrections confirming this happened but
a spokesperson saying she doesn't have
additional details to provide at this
time we don't know whether any inmates
are facing charges in connection with
the alleged fentanyl found this is the
same prison where an inmate was murdered
after his cellmate issued a warning and
where there was a cluster of inmate
suicides we do know Staffing is a major
issue at the Nevada Department of
Corrections and there is an issue with
drugs getting inside state prisons but
again a correctional officer exposed to
a substance believed to be possible
Fentanyl and that officer is expected to
be okay Vanessa Murphy ate news now and
as the 8 news now investigators first
reported here on Thursday come Monday
the Nevada Department of Corrections
will have a new director James zorinda
returns in fact he'd resigned from the
very same job back in 2019 and Governor
Joe Lombardo is bringing him back